seeing the players making so many  mistakes by now it is very hard to  predict to be honest because i was  extremely optimistic about thing  seeing him playing the way he played in  those three rounds where he started to  win one game after another so that was  extremely exciting whether he can gone  and win on the games  at the end of the candidate and then he  was losing this game against rajabo  which was quite a big  break in this this speedy winning right  so  that stopped him and that was not a very  good sign the way he was there against  rojava with white  in 25 moves or something like that  so  uh i don't know  well somehow i i would predict that  hikaru will be number two  it feels like any time anyone's in a  must-win situation in this tournament it  seems to backfire so  yeah we'll see nakamura super solid in  the other hand when you have to win  it means that you have to and you have  no choice then to give everything all in  right